Tony, Colin, congratulations.
The two of you
are moving forward
to the third and final
round of this competition.
Now, in this last
round, we're going
to send you back
to your home forges
to build an iconic
weapon from history.
Gentlemen, we want
you to build this.
The Burmese dha.
Holy moly.
Hell yeah.
NARRATOR: The Burmese
dha traces its roots back
to 16th century southeast Asia.
The single edged, double
handed sword features
a slightly curved
blade, designed
to inflict deep deadly, slashes
against enemies in battle.
The weapon was so
effective, soldiers
continued to use it in combat
through World War II, where
US-aided resistance forces,
known as Kachin Rangers,
wielded this blade fighting
in the hills of Myanmar.
Bladesmiths,
you guys will have
four days to build your
Burmese dhas, so good luck.
We'll see you then.
My name is Tony Bravo.
I'm 46 years old.
I'm a journeyman lineman,
and a part time bladesmith.
Back home, I have a lot
of people rooting for me.
I've got two daughters.
My youngest is going off to
college, so those $10,000
would definitely come in handy.
This is a timed
competition, so you
want to make sure that
everything sticks,
and you've got a
solid piece of steel.
We have a heat treated
and tempered blade,
and now I'm going
to blue the spine
to give it some more durability.
Yeah, I'm starting
to see some color.
We're getting there.
So by keeping the
blade in the wet sand,
it's going to act
as an insulator,
and it's going to prevent
the heat from traveling down.
Little by little.
If I do it right,
I'm going to have
a shock-absorbing spine that
will withstand any type of test
that they put on it.
I chose to go with Osage
orange on my handle material
because it's a hard wood.
It'll survive any blow that
they're going to give it.
Everything is good.
I got it fitted, it looks great.
It's going to do some damage.
[bleep]
I almost hit the ground.
[laughter]
My name is Colin Roy.
I'm 28, and I'm
a full time metal
fabricator and blacksmith.
Started in my parents'
one car garage.
I almost burned it down
twice, but I finally saved up
enough money, I was able
to build my own shop,
and that's where I'm
working out of today.
I'm way ahead of schedule.
I can get the blade
quenched today.
All right, I think
we're going for it.
It's now or never.
I feel my whole body tense
up as I dunk it in the oil.
Yep, we're good.
That looks [bleep] cool.
I want to keep the
momentum going.
And that's when I see it.
I got a real big
warp in the blade.
Aw, that sucks.
It's a bit of a corkscrew,
and that's something
I can't bend or grind out.
Looks like I'm going to
have to re-quench my blade.
I am dreading having
to quench again.
See what happens.
Blade goes in the oil--
woo!
Comes out, I get
it clamped down.
Looks like I got the
warp almost out of it.
It looks good enough for now.
I think we're good.
That is perfect.
I get my handles
all fit together.
Everything's
looking really good,
and I spend a lot of time
polishing everything, getting
a really nice finish on it.
This is one of the best
places I've ever made.
In my mind, this is
a winning weapon.
Tony, I'll see you
at the competition.
Better bring your A game.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the kill test.
Your Burmese dhas
are beautiful--
but are they deadly?
To find that out, I'm
going to take your weapons
and deliver some lethal
blows on this pig carcass.
Tony, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Absolutely.
All right.
So am I. Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Tony, let's talk
about your weapon here.
This is a gorgeous piece.
The handle construction, for me,
is a little bit on the larger
side, but every
cut, every thrust
is very sharp on
this pig carcass.
And overall, sir,
your Burmese dha--
it will kill.
Thank you, sir.
All right Colin,
your turn, sir.
You ready?
- Yep.
All right, let's do this.
[music playing]
Aw, come on.
That was a big slice.
All right, Colin, let's
talk about your weapon here.
Stunningly beautiful.
Damascus [inaudible].
Beautiful handle.
Easier to control, because
it's a little bit smaller.
Now, your edge is very sharp.
Your tip thrusts
and slashes nicely.
But you already had a little
bit of a warp earlier--
now it's even more pronounced.
But overall, sir, your weapon--
it will kill.
Hell yeah.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to our strength test.
Now I'm going to take your
beautiful Damascus swords
and beat the heck out of
them against these guys
in the armor, and
shields, and helmets.
Now, what your blades
do to these dummies
is not as important
to me as what
the dummies do to your blades.
Tony, you're up first.
Ready to go?
Get you some.
I can do that.
Definitely worried
about that initial impact.
They're trying to
break your blade.
It could be disastrous.
[grunting]
[music playing]
All right, Tony.
Breathe.
This held up well.
You do have a little
glinting here and there,
but compared to what was
done to that, that's great.
Bladw'a still straight.
Everything else is
still razor sharp.
Good job.
Hot diggity dog.
All right, Colin.
How you feeling, bud?
Well, we'll know
when it's done.
Well, let's find out, then.
Here we go.
[grunting]
[music playing]
Colin, you survived.
I'm gonna start
with your handle.
The smaller diameter gives
me a little more control,
a little easier to hold onto.
But counterbalance is nice.
We've got some minor
glinting, but you've
still got a good edge on there.
It's still sharp, so
, overall nice job.
Thank you.
All right, bladesmiths.
This is the sharpness
test, the tatami mat slice.
I'm going to take
your weapon and try
to across these tatami mats.
Tony, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Let's do it, sir.
Let's do it.
[music playing]
All right, right, Tony, let's
talk about your weapon here.
Your edge does cut very well.
Overall, sir, your weapon--
it will cut.
Thank you.
Colin, your turn, sir.
You ready?
Yep.
Let's do it.
[music playing]
All right, Colin, let's
talk about your weapon here.
When the edges make contact with
the tatami mats, it will cut.
Thank you.
All right guys,
your Burmese dhas
show that you are both
very skilled bladesmiths,
but the judges have decided
who the "Forged in Fire"
champion is, and
today that smith is--
Tony.
Congratulations.
Now, Colin, you crushed it,
but unfortunately, you're
not the "Forged in
Fire" champion today,
and Doug's going
to tell you why.
Colin, you brought
us a beautiful weapon,
but your weapon was
the only one that
took some damage
during the kill test,
where you developed the warp.
That's the reason
you didn't win today.
Understood.
Well, Colin, unfortunately,
your time in this competition
has ended.
I'm gonna have to
ask you to please
step off the Forged floor, but
thank you for your hard work.
Thank you.
I'm really disappointed
that I'm getting
sent home for that stupid warp.
I should have just
made a new blade.
But it was a real
close competition.
If I'm going to lose to
someone, I'm glad it was Tony.
[bleep] warps.
Well, Tony, it was not an
easy road, but you did it.
You are the newest
"Forged in Fire" champion.
You just won yourself
a check for $10,000.
Congratulations.
Woo!
This challenge
really made me realize,
whatever you want to
do, go out and do it.
Just be the best at it.
My name is Tony, and I am the
"Forged in Fire" champion.